[Music]
these are desperate times for russian
leader vladimir putin
his regime stands accused of poisoning
his main political rival in russia
alexei navalny with the deadly nerve
agent novichok
the poisoning suggested of a measure of
desperation that the regime
in russia has run out of arguments and
now has to
resort to shia violence
but events in neighbouring belarus show
violence alone isn't always enough to
maintain control
[Music]
protesters there have braved
state-sponsored terror
to demand that dictator alexander
lukashenko steps down
and the kremlin is watching as thousands
of miles away in far eastern russia
protesters have also been on the street
for weeks
they say they stand with belarus so
should putin be worried
putin's legitimacy is waning then this
is extraordinary events to watch
we're seeing history in the making here
[Music]
on august 9th alexander lukashenko
the longest-serving autocrat in europe
declared a landslide election victory in
belarus
he came to power in 1994 and since then
not one of his elections has been free
or fair
but this time the people refused to
accept the rigged result
it sparked the largest popular protest
in belarus's history
one of the leaders of the opposition
maria kolesnikova
was on the streets in the capital mints
use of violence has intensified ten days
after we interviewed maria kolesnikova
she was abducted by mr lukashenko's
plane clothed
security goons she's now in prison
only two months ago nothing suggested
this
this was coming lukashenko has rigged
elections
for years he had everything under
control and it's like with metal you
know metal develops a fatigue
but you don't know when it's going to
break
the speed and scale of the revolt has
rattled putin
while neighbouring russia and belarus
are different in many ways
their two leaders have some similarities
both putin and lukashenko pledged to
restore stability
after the soviet collapse and both
change the constitution
so they can effectively stay in power
forever
and both rely on the threat or use of
violence to maintain control
belarus is important because it is a
template
for in a way for what's been happening
in russia and what might come
in russia if even somebody like
lokashanko
can be so brutal and changes can be so
unexpected
then that changes your calculation about
how long
putin can actually stay in power himself
discontent has been building up for
years in belarus
the state-run economy had stalled and
lukashenko's promises to restore
soviet-style order and pride were
increasingly meaningless to the new
generation
then covert 19 struck lukashenko refused
to impose lockdowns
and even said the virus did not exist
this mobilized civil society to step in
where their leader had failed
people started crowdfunding buying
protective
equipment for doctors delivering that
protective equipment
informing people about what's happening
they took over the function of the state
the energy of civic activism then flowed
and morphed into political activism
[Music]
this popular revolution has become a
national awakening
after years of soviet-style rule
it was led by three women headed by
svetlana tikanovsky
she only stood because her husband a
political vlogger who wanted to run for
the presidency
had been jailed are you confident that
the
uprising will win i believe in my people
in people of belarus
as the protest spread she was threatened
and fled to lithuania
maria kolesnikova was the last member of
the original opposition left in belarus
until she disappeared
while protests raged in belarus
thousands of miles away in hebarask
a city in russia's far east another
popular movement has been gaining ground
demonstrators have been on the street
since july protesting against the arrest
of a popular local governor
who was elected against the kremlin's
wishes
when the revolution in belarus had
started suddenly the slogans
in khabarovs are long-lived belarus
is that connection that should be a
moment of worry
for the kremlin with anti-government
protests in both russia's far east
and minsk the putin regime took decisive
action
on august 20th opposition leader alexei
navalny was poisoned with the nerve
agent novichok
which was allegedly found on a water
bottle in his hotel room
this has provoked international
condemnation
the mystery about what made a russian
opposition leader critically ill
has been
while navalny himself is banned from
standing for office
he had been encouraging his supporters
to vote tactically in forthcoming local
elections
and while he had been imprisoned and
attacked many times before
there had never been a direct attempt on
his life like this
having a leader who will be seen as
legitimate
by protesters and possibly by parts of
the elite is now too risky
[Music]
and so this is the step that bhutan's
regime has taken to
to take him out of the picture and then
something went wrong
when mr navalny was taken ill on a
flight over siberia
the pilot made in an emergency landing
paramedics were then able to reach him
identify he had been poisoned
and administer an antidote
by the time he reached hospital security
services and state media
tried to take control of the story and
claimed he might simply have fainted due
to hunger
but it was too late his life had been
saved and the truth was out
the human response to this situation
could not have been predicted or planned
because contrary to what vladimir putin
and alexander think
humans do have their own free will
this shows you actually putin doesn't
control everything
navalny's candidates won symbolic
victories in the local elections
he is now recovering in germany and
while the actions of a pilot or
paramedic in siberia
may seem far removed from the rallying
cry of protesters in belarus
the actions of both show that putin and
lukashenko
are not all-powerful when people have
individual will
as they do um the regimes don't know how
to deal with that
they only stay in power for as long as
they maintain
legitimacy once they've lost that things
start happening and this is what we're
seeing now this
this is why this is a really historic
moment
[Music]
putin cannot be beaten through the
ballot box and his main opposition is
out of the picture
for now at least but if lukashenko falls
it will send a signal to people in
russia that dictatorial rulers can
beaten
putin has now promised lukashenko 1.5
billion dollars
to help prop up the regime and while it
is impossible to predict
exactly when or how lukashenko will fall
the european parliament says his
presidency should not be recognised from
november
this summer's events have shown putin is
unsettled and scared
which makes what happens next
increasingly unpredictable
and dangerous i'm mark ideastrovsky and
i'm the russia editor at the economist
if you'd like to know more about events
in belarus or the poisoning of alexey
navalny or the protest in khabarovsk
you can click on the link opposite
you